hello everyone and welcome to the
european parliament here in brussels
my name is maria and together with
robert we invite you to join this live
chat with the freshly elected president
of the european parliament roberta
mizola
welcome president venezuela and thank
you for joining us thank you so much
thanks for inviting me
thank you and a warm welcome to everyone
who just tuned in on our live stream on
facebook youtube instagram and on
linkedin many of you have already sent
us questions and thank you very much for
that we'll try to put as many as we can
to president mitzola but you haven't if
you haven't done so yet in the comment
sections you can still do it in the next
30 minutes
so first of all congratulations on your
election you are the third female
president of the european parliament and
also the youngest ever what does all
this mean to you
well first of all it's a great honour
and a privilege to have been entrusted
with a big responsibility from my
colleagues just three weeks ago feels
like much longer than than these three
weeks
it was
also a message that in this parliament
in this campaign you had a number of
women running for this post
whereby this institution said it was
about time it's been 20 years since a
woman headed disposed and what i said
in my introductory speech that i will do
everything to ensure that no more 20
years will pass for there to be another
woman but it is not just about me it is
not only about image it's now about
making sure that the equality we work
for and we represent is taken out of
this parliament and also implemented in
different member states so that people
looking into this parliament from
outside can see in this parliament
something that they can also do
you are also the first maltese president
of a european institution on this vasco
mederas on linkedin would like to know
how you feel about it well first of all
i thank vasco he is not
the first one to ask me this question i
come from
an island in the middle of the
mediterranean sea
a very proud
island and also one that worked very
hard to join the european union and be
an equal partner
around the table
with so many other countries bigger
than malta but that also have
recognized the fact that we have values
and rights that we all share and it is
those that we fought for in my
generation when we
uh engaged in in a battle at the time to
join the european union that meant that
those rights have to continue to be
protected and that's what matters
actually also to the citizens of my
country when they look at the european
union and everything it represents
today
the parliament uh europe a new public
opinion survey was released
also to measure the sentiment of people
on the work of the european parliament
and public health was one of the main
topic the actually the priority number
one that citizens think the the
parliament should address what is your
it's also fueled by the pandemic of
course but what is your assessment of
the of the management of this pandemic
by the eu and what should be done you
think uh to
tackle future crisis yeah i think
these kind of surveys where we tap into
citizens concerns and listen to them as
to what they want the european
parliament to do are some of the most
effective tools that we have
that we need to use and respond to and
as you said the pandemic
has led to people analyzing their
concerns understanding that health is a
priority
also coincidentally an area where the
european union until today does not have
a lot of competence but
even though
there is not that competence when it
mattered all the european union member
states all the members of parliament in
this house got together and said we have
to do something about it we need to make
sure that we join forces on equipment
then on vaccines on rolling out the
vaccines as quickly as possible that
there was no citizen no one living in
the european union no matter how far
away from strasbourg or brussels no
matter how far away from the capital
city of his or her country they live in
they said i have equal access to all the
services provided that came because the
european union led and this european
parliament was at the forefront in
leading that charge
climate change should be another
priority for the european parliaments
according to to what europeans answered
in this public opinion survey as well
this especially concerns younger
generations who chose climate change as
a top priority so to answer to sarah
valerio and haley from instagram is the
european union doing enough to meet the
climate targets the european union is
never doing enough to meet climate
targets why this is an urgency
we cannot wait uh any longer to say this
is something that can be done by a
future generation and it is no wonder uh
that our younger generation tell us you
need to tackle it now this is something
that they can feel as i said i come from
an island it is also extremely visible
to us
uh for whoever lives close to the sea
and can and and can feel the changes
happening every every day this
parliament has been uh very ambitious it
will continue to be ambitious it has
gone further and also in pushing other
institutions in this town and going
further in its targets now we need to
implement them it is no longer about
agreeing on big words we have laws on
the table now and we need to negotiate
them and put them forward so that we
really
rethink where we get our energy from
rethink how we're going to make sure
that there are no
big gaps in the in the accessibility and
no and the margin of poverty in
different member states is also
addressed after the pandemic new sectors
of society have become even more and
more isolated all this brought together
are what the young people are telling us
to fix and it is up to us because we are
the last generation that can fix that
i'm coming back to the pandemic which
has exacerbated inequalities in the eu
22 percent of the population affected by
poverty and social exclusion uh fighting
poverty is also the third priority for
the citizens according to this uh same
survey uh for the parliament to tackle
what do you think talk to us about the
role that the eu can play in tackling
these issues
first of all we just mentioned
legislation you are right that when we
see the numbers and the effects that the
pandemic has
had even on the mental health
of our citizens top priority for a lot
of of countries that has to be addressed
increased poverty mostly and i have to
say that the gender also plays that more
women have suffered as a result of the
pandemic because of their inability to
re-enter the market more domestic
violence
incidents have been reported because of
people having been locked down in their
home so the first role of the european
parliament i believe is to bring that
awareness to the fore so that when it
comes to elections when it comes to
decisions that are being taken when it
comes to discussing the conference on
the future of europe which we are
currently all together saying where does
the european union want to go what have
we done so far where have we failed but
where have we succeeded there this
european parliament can say we can do
more and in fact when we're talking
about the unprecedented amount of funds
that were approved just behind me a
little a few meters away in the in the
plenary chamber in brussels here but
also
in strasbourg we agreed on an
unprecedented amount of funds that would
go into the economic recovery but this
includes social measures this could
include the green transition the digital
transformation all of these
matter in making sure that we can plug
the gaps that are still so apparent in
some member states more than others
another thing that i think we need to do
more of is continue the awareness on
vaccination the vaccination rate in too
many member states remains too low and
we as we have said since the beginning
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
that still remains the case today even
as a national government and even this
institution is totally try starting to
come out of a very difficult couple of
years but it needs to take leadership
and it needs to take solidarity between
our peoples
and we have noticed that uh the lifting
of extreme
uh of uh of restrictions in some member
countries is uh is different and it has
also been the the the concern of many
people who commented on on our posts uh
you also have continuously delivered
very bold statements and i quote uh to
against those who deny rights to the
lgbtiq community but despite the
freedoms we enjoy not every lgbtiq
person living in the eu
enjoys the same rights as in for example
your home country malta which is has one
of the most progressive lgbtiq laws in
europe so what do you think the
parliament can do to to
to promote more inclusive legislation
i tell you something the first thing i
worked on in this parliament when i
arrived nine years ago as a member was
an
anti-homophobia roadmap
for the european parliament and the
european union i must tell you that if i
had known then from 2013 the advances we
would make specifically because of
resolutions and
recommendations made in this parliament
by big majorities
of members coming from all political
groups i would not have believed you but
today i think that it is thanks also to
a a very bold generation of politicians
that have broken barriers in their
member state and said if
i have fought so much for my rights to
be equal to those in other member states
then i expect my politicians and my
representatives to deliver on that there
are of course certain areas where things
fall within the companies of member
states but this european parliament has
been very very vocal also in making sure
for example when there was the lgbtiq
free zones in poland we were the
institution that adopted an extremely
strong resolution condemning that plaque
backsliding of rights in poland at that
specific specific moment and of course
it takes you say bold but it also takes
a responsibility we are elected not just
to to say things that are you know
comfortable or easy to say sometimes you
get elected also to do things that are
difficult that are unpopular so to speak
not in this area but in other areas if
we have a responsibility to making sure
that human rights are seen and observed
everywhere that you have the freedom to
love who you want to love and live where
you want to live across our union and we
have to be the ones the beacons that
guarantee that
indeed the fight against gender
inequality and discrimination has also
been other of your closest to political
concern and this is also a priority for
young people so what could be your ideal
equality policy
well for me is that where i see
inequality this european parliament
needs to act
and this is in all areas we see for
example still that women get paid much
less than men um across the european
union in some cases better than others
but in some cases much worse than others
this european parliament has been very
vocal uh in that area also by being an
example one of the things that i have
committed to for example is to make sure
that even within
the administration of this parliament
you have as much equality and pluralism
between genders and political
representation that matters also and
reflects the proportional representation
of this house because that's how you
have to take decisions not only by
preaching but to do them um
inside inside your own house and of
course i get asked a lot by journalists
but are you going to do that everywhere
and my answer is very clear and
unequivocal i will take this position in
every single member state and every city
i go in the european union
we got many questions about sexual and
reproductive rights and health what it
what's parliament's position on this on
this i can continue just where i left
off the parliament's position is
extremely clear the rights have to be
enjoyed and promoted any everywhere and
that is the position that i will promote
as european parliament president that is
what i committed to and that is why
there are at the moment negotiations on
the so-called simon vale pact that seeks
to promote rights but also bring member
states together closer together um
keeping in mind member states competence
on this matter but on this my position
is clear my position is that is that of
the european parliament
more than half of eu cities since stated
in the in this public survey that they
want parliament to have a stronger role
in the eu
on this lian on instagram asked what can
be done to strengthen the parliament's
role on the eu
we have a golden opportunity now first
of all to transform into a modern
effective and efficient parliament we
have learned a lot during the pandemic
we are now looking into the
opportunities that we of what we learned
not only in using it in the way we work
here and the way we negotiate in the way
we communicate our decisions but also in
being a model for other parliaments
across the world
concretely we would like to do more in
terms of legislative initiative you know
there is a possibility for parliament
this parliament to initiate laws we we
know because we are the only directly
elected institution that there are gaps
in our legislative arsenal so to speak
what we can do citizens are asking us to
do more let's make sure we don't hide
behind political inability or sometimes
unwillingness by saying there is no
solution i am a fixer and i've always
wanted to find solutions to problems
which seem unsurmountable but we have
been here before there was a time when
this parliament was not a co-legislator
when this parliament used to simply give
consent sign on the dotted line whenever
there was a law that was adopted across
the road now we are co-legislators now
we have equality in the way we do laws
and i think that we need to make sure
that that role is pushed reinforced and
also delivers on what our citizens
want us to legislate upon and sometimes
you know there is a gap it's what we are
doing when we say it and what we do i
want to shorten that gap and be more
relevant
anna bondi from instagram asks what are
the three most important things we must
do and she puts in brackets besides your
vision i agree with her
to make europe more united eurovision is
important absolutely
totally agreed
in my country too
i think on climate we need to do more on
health with as we said we need to do
more but also i think we could be more
coherent and
consistent in foreign policy we have so
many
people messaging us from all over on on
facebook and on instagram telling us i
would like to hear a coherent voice i
live in a country which is worried about
a neighboring country that is not a
member of the european union and seeks
to trample on my rights seeks to
destabilize the union i think we can do
more and thanks to anna for for asking
the question on a foreign policy
perspective this european parliament has
long held very strong positions i think
it's about time also to align those
positions with the other institutions
because the competence is the same and
we can really deliver not only in
political uh in political statements but
tangible results in expressing
solidarity with those people
there is also a nice questions from
vicenzo from instagram and it says is it
still possible to make the dream of our
founding fathers come true namely of a
european of europe as an only a united
community of politics and defense
this is something that
occurs every time we discuss uh um
issues where we have failed where we
have succeeded and in reality he is
right vincenzo by saying listen
we have been talking about this for
decades
and we still have not delivered and
there are gaps uh in our possible in in
our capacity to act in a united manner
at the moment there are talks of the
so-called strategic autonomy what does
europe do where other parts of the world
don't act or if they act
how do we defend ourselves how do we
help those individual member states that
need solidarity here you have a delicate
path of analyzing different statuses of
different member states where they stand
but this european parliament has always
also been very clear in expressing
solidarity with those people who look to
europe
as they did to the founding fathers as
the beacon of hope prosperity democracy
but ultimately of rights
uh this same survey released today also
uh note that uh for your eu citizens
democracy is important but to protect
this democracy also as you said to
protect it from what's coming from
outside this information from the third
parties from actors uh uh foreign actors
uh is imminent in europe and it the eu
is fighting it
so
mark oliver asks what
should what is the what should the u.s
response be to to targeted campaigns
especially those funded by the by russia
for example disinformation and
misinformation by authoritarian regimes
is something that is becoming let's say
more tangible influencing
elections looking into spreading fake
root
and
even as we see
destabilizing
governments that are constructive in
order to try to emerge from this
pandemic we see also a need to counter
that narrative
at the extreme ends of the political
spectrum which try to misuse this
information again to destabilize or
spread fake news such as for example
rising energy prices are because of the
green deal proposals on the table which
is of course not a reality in this
parliament we have set up a committee
that is was set up precisely
to discuss uh and and how to combat this
misinformation and disinformation we
have been discussing this with tech
giants and social media operators and
network operators in order to see how to
protect the most vulnerable members of
our society especially our children who
are you know who have sometimes been
seen as victims of such of such misuse
of data and misinformation the report
and i look very much forward to reading
it is presented to our parliament in
march and then we will take the steps
forward from there
you have already mentioned that we need
to bring europe closer to towns and to
villages across europe and romaine from
instagram would like to know how to
reconnect european institutions to
citizens
if i can tell you what my favorite part
of being an mvp a member of the european
parliament is is to enter a school
and discuss with children of all ages
why
they should believe in politics
why politics is not a bad word why
if you vote it makes a difference why
because if you don't vote people who you
might not feel represented by will fill
that gap and take decisions that you
don't like or are not good for you
the
reaction of going and doing that not
only in your member state but in each
and every part of the european union and
i had already started doing that when i
was vice president and i will definitely
continue to do that now as president is
priceless because they get to see that
european union is not only about what
happens in this building it's not only
about what happens in our building in
strasbourg or also in luxembourg where
we also have
have um
workforce people who work for the
european parliament
who who live and work in luxembourg but
but that you go out of these cities into
the member states and say i'm here ask
me what you want and i'm here to deliver
and it could be the most rural
far away par part from the capital uh of
of a country it is so important that the
european union is present and the
european parliament represents everybody
living on our territory
actually on this we have a question as
well by and sirica from instagram and
she wonders how difficult is to succeed
in in politics as a woman
i think
i have to thank
women who came before me
for having worked so hard
to break those feelings those barriers
in order for me and my colleagues in
this house
40 members are women we need to have
more but if you look at the current
composition of the bureau the vice
presidents more women than men so
different scenario to what has been for
all these decades
it is
us that we need to thank
uh for the example for the effort of
those women who came before us and on
whose shoulders as i said in my in my
speech when i got elected we stand with
pride with honor but with an obligation
to make sure that we pass on
this overcome challenge still many
challenges to go to the women and girls
who come after us
for those who for doing those young
girls girls who are watching us now what
would be the advice you could give them
right now
make sure your voice is heard
never wait for somebody else to talk for
you you have a voice that can be as loud
and the integrity of your argument can
matter irrespective of where you come
from
where you live which country you are
currently in you could be traveling you
could be working you could be
visiting another member state but you
could be in your house today watching
after you've come back from school after
you've come back from work or if you're
still at work and connected to the
european parliament to see what you are
doing make sure you make your voice
heard
for
uh many people
maybe do not know that you are married
to a finn so your family is truly
european from south to north absolutely
but
there must be some cultural differences
different or that one culture difference
that you still find odd even after these
years you know we say united in
diversity i think that is very good
statement to
to
explain my marriage i met my husband
from finland when we were in youth
politics
when we were doing i was doing actually
a lot of the same things i'm doing now
uh in in seeking
a role of convincing people to vote
and engage themselves from the ground in
a campaign
cultural difference
linguistic there is for sure
i would say perhaps not the sauna you
know this is a very specific finnish
nordic but mostly finnish
tradition which my husband engages in
very actively
i have learned to get accustomed to that
but they also have this very weird thing
of digging a hole in the ice and jumping
into it i'm never going to do that not
for a mediterranean
never
and maybe before we wrap up there is a
question from liz lindberg on linkedin
she asks how young people can contribute
or engage in the future of the european
union
they have the opportunity to do that now
it's not only about voting we are
currently engaged in the discussions on
the conference on the future of europe
big panels given and dedicated to young
people in most in a lot of member states
whether it is online a lot of pandas
have taken place online but in a lot of
countries they are being they are taking
place with big communication
possibilities uh in presence
send your messages we will listen to
them it's our responsibility because in
2024 i need to convince together with my
colleagues here that this place is worth
keeping because we work for you
and thanks for mentioning the conference
on the future of europe which is still
uh ongoing and ideas are taking shape
now and will be soon presented to the
european parliament so hopefully you
will keep them coming exactly keep them
coming and you have also promised that
you will come back to our uh
live chats yes uh so we hope to have you
back soon thank you so much looking
forward thank you and thank you to
everyone who has uh followed this live
stream
thank you so much president metzolia and
thank you everyone for tuning in thank
you have a good afternoon bye
you